hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I'm gonna be
watching the Fifty Shades of Grey
official Golden Globe spot I'm actually
really intrigued by this movie sure guys
can hate on me as much as they want but
this movie looks [ __ ] sexy I really
want to check it out I'm intrigued by it
so much I haven't read a book in years
but I got the Fifty Shades of Grey put I
am planning on reading this and then
checking it out because I hear there's a
lot of [ __ ] in and a lot of [ __ ]
so let's watch this trailer - what do
you owe your success there's some people
who say that I don't have a heart why do
you say that because they know me what
do I do I get the feeling that that is
not true
you do admit he's ridiculously hot if
you are attracted to that rough start in
life I don't do romance
mother Anastasia Steele yeah no idea why
did I have to meet you
he said you didn't do romance I don't
are you coming to me
they are perfect perfect it says it's
rated R for strong sexual content
including dialogue some unusual behavior
and graphic nudity and for language how
can you not want to watch this movie
it's like a modern-day Basic Instinct in
a way I wonder how many people I pissed
off by saying that I mean everything
about this movie you just look super
intriguing to me the way it's shot looks
really [ __ ] cool like it looks
captured really well the cinematography
looks excellent I mean even in the early
part of the trailer when he's like
putting on a shirt and in his closet and
stuff I'm like that looks like one cool
closet
I love the crazy and love rendition that
Beyonce is doing for this I hope that
music is using the trailer because the
music is [ __ ] incredible I would love
to make love with that music playing in
the background it's so fast and I know
this started off as like Twilight erotic
fan fiction or something honestly this
looks better than Twilight that's why I
can go suck it this film looks [ __ ]
cool this Dorian Gray guy he I'm not gay
that's [ __ ] and I blow him because he
is [ __ ] sexy it goes beyond his six
back like just the way he carries
himself the swag he doesn't look like a
tree : it's a little bit interesting to
me how this is like inspired by Twilight
fan fiction because there's the
similarities of course but Dorian Gray
like he is like I see what the hype is
all about
I forgot the main character's name the
girl they look like they actually have
some real chemistry in this it doesn't
look like that Kristen Stewart you know
Robert Pattinson crap I'm I don't mean
to just compare this whole thing to
Twilight it's a Valentine's Day film
it's a sexual like erotic I think it's a
thriller I'm not sure you know at the
end of the day you want these two main
characters to have like awesome sexual
chemistry and they look like they really
do I'm interested in seeing the
psychology behind Dorian Gray I mean I
hope they explore that because he says
he had a rough start in his life and
then it leads into all like the
matrix BDSM stuff that stuff I've never
actually tried it but I'm sure after
this movie there's gonna be a lot of us
who are trying some think about it just
seems so interesting to me like is it
are they falling in love or are they
falling and lust see how I did that
Wow I'm really efficient with my words
but yeah Valentine's Day I'm taking
Veronica she has no other choice we're
gonna go watch this film anyway guys if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects where we
talk about so much stuff
shout outs nephew not gorni hey guys
your channel is awesome I love your
videos
can I have a shout out please PS they
had a little rhyme for me
hey little Ryan Mathew luck or name
wants to say hi you want to say hi to
little Ryan that he ma th ie yo dude
after 50 shades of grey I'm sure we're
gonna be a lot more experimental so yeah
if you want to say hi a little Ryan in
person just wait til after Valentine's
Day Justin like Gary
Legere hey Ryan I love the videos man
keep them up this is my favorite channel
on YouTube now I'm glad always find
myself laughing at all of your vids and
hey with all the girls we have on the
channel it gives me something to look at
as well so thanks man well that's good
I'm glad you can look at the hot girls
on this channel you know we got Veronica
Sally Alyssa Lauren and we'll be making
a comeback soon but then we got Samantha
and brandy and you know like it was like
The Bachelor when it first started I had
to choose between all of them and it was
it wasn't thought of at all it was just
like alright Branca I want Veronica
that's right you're watching baby
I [ __ ] up that wink but Justin it is a
flat to read sure to say that this is
your favorite channel I mean you must
not obviously watch a lot of channels
because this is not the best one there's
a lot more creative channels out there
than us I just sit here and talk out of
my ass but if that's your kind of thing
then okay my friend
okay Justin if you want to say I had a
little rhyme one day - just let me know